Magical flying hammers may make for great
weapons in the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
but according to Chris Hemsworth's wife, they
don't make for great house decor.
Most actors like to take home a piece of memorabilia
from the sets of their films like small props
or a piece of clothing to remind them of a
special time in their life or an important
character they played.
If you're the God of Thunder, however, your
eyes are firmly affixed on your faithful hammer,
Mjolnir.
“Myeu Muh?
What's Myeu Muh?”
Thor, whom Hemsworth has played in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe since the release of…
well, Thor in 2011, is known to wield Mjolnir
at all times in combat, making frequent use
of a deadly swing that could knock even the
Hulk out of his boots if the green monster
wore any, of course.
The enchanted weapon has certainly proven
useful on screen for both combat and for just
getting around, and Hemsworth has apparently
taken a huge liking to it in real life, bringing
several of the prop hammers home with him
after wrapping films in the MCU.
While the Aussie actor loves having them around,
his wife, model and actress Elsa Pataky, has
reached her limit on the prop in their home,
so much so that she's imposed a strict rule:
Hemsworth absolutely has to quit swiping hammers
from set.
Speaking on the Australian radio show Fitzy
and Wippa, Pataky shared that her husband
has snatched not just one prop Mjolnir...
"How many hammers do you have?"
"Uhhh… about five?"
"Five hammers!"
Now, don't get us wrong Mjolnir is an epic
weapon to wield, but that's an awful lot of
hammers for people in the house to trip over.
Especially considering, y'know, some mere
mortal can't just lift it up and move it over
a few inches unless they're also wielding
America's ass, that is.
Yeah, you know who we're talking about.
Jokes aside, Pataky also explained that she
and Hemsworth have regular arguments over
where the props are and aren't allowed to
go in the house.
She dished:
"He always picks the best places in the house,
and I'm like, 'It's not going there.
We have five of them [ … ] like, seriously,
no."
Of course, Thor would want his trusty Mjolnir
close at hand at all times, so Hemsworth wants
to make sure the hammers are prominently displayed
all over the couple's Australian home in case
of emergency or maybe in case he needs a last-minute
gift.
Remind us which year is the "enchanted Asgardian
hammer" anniversary?
We also can't imagine Pataky would have been
any happier if her husband brought home Thor's
second weapon.
Stormbreaker the giant battle axe Thor helps
forge after his sister Hela destroys Mjolnir
in Thor: Ragnarok is just a tad bigger than
the hammer, so here's hoping Pataky hasn't
had to find a space for this significantly
larger weapon in the house.
Unfortunately for Pataky, the flow of hammers
isn't likely to stop flowing anytime soon,
despite her ban.
Hemsworth is set to appear as Thor again in
Thor: Love and Thunder, which is set for release
in November 2021.
Though Pataky has put her foot down and warned
him not to bring more hammers home, Hemsworth
seems like the cheeky type who might want
just one extra prop, and Pataky just might
have to find space for more of her husband's
very unique brand of decor.
Thor: Love and Thunder will see a new hero
rise up to take the mantle and powers of Thor:
the God of Thunder's former love interest,
Jane Foster played by Natalie Portman is set
to make a return to the MCU after seemingly
quitting for good following 2013's Thor: The
Dark World.
In the upcoming flick, fans will get to see
Jane wield Mjolnir when she becomes the Mighty
Thor.
Hopefully for Pataky, Portman will be the
one taking the hammer home this time around.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.